Donald Trump was being interviewed by
Sean Hannity and he was giving credit to
Elon Musk for what he's done with
Twitter and you guys know I I've been to
Twitter Elon seems like he's doing the
best he can I still have a ton of
frustrations with Twitter the numbers
still seem completely out of whack the
engagement still seems really bizarre he
called it a fractal Rube Goldberg
machine to me so it's not an easy thing
to clean up but Trump talked about at
least the fact that Elon got in the
fight and whether he's going to get back
on Twitter
by the way Elon Musk revalued Twitter at
only 20 million well it was not uh 20
billion I'm sorry but he did a big favor
by letting people know how corrupt our
government is you know I hear that they
spied in my campaign and at that time
because truth is incredible but at that
time I was using Twitter now I use truth
although I have they want me back on
Twitter desperately are you going to go
back uh well we'll talk about that at
some point but I love truth I think
truth is incredible it's it's up I think
389 it's the hottest thing there is
okay uh Josh
ah just talk what do you got
um so look I mean let's not forget the
Twitter files I mean I share a lot of
the same frustrations that you probably
have Dave with the low engagement
numbers the fact that there's this weird
for you for you column on my iPhone app
for Twitter now
um engagement is just really I I feel
like I'm Shadow banned frankly worse
than ever but let's not forget about the
Twitter files I mean honestly the
Twitter files really kind of I think
makes Elon Musk doing this worth it unto
itself the revelations in there were
absolutely positively striking and they
really just confirmed so much of what
those of us have been saying or
suspecting for years now about this just
naked open collusion between the
National Security State the intelligence
community and Silicon Valley so that in
and of itself I think really did justify
and make this whole experiment that Elon
Musk is doing worth it but really just
more symbolically the fact that someone
could come in there and obviously you
know very few people have you on must
net worth but the the mere example that
someone could kind of come in there like
a white knight and try to pry away a
very prominent and important social
media media platform away from kind of
the Jack Dorsey clown Brigade despite
its CR my current frustrations with
what's happening there and the fact that
we're very far from Perfection there is
some in you know some inherent value in
Merit in that act yeah and by the way as
of March 31st which is today uh Elon
supposedly is open sourcing this thing
that's what he had said in a tweet a
couple weeks ago we'll see if it
actually open sources today and then at
least if it was truly open source you'd
be able to see how your account was
being affected perhaps by the language
you use or inserting a link or saying
something about someone's gender Etc
actually I'll give you the final word
yeah I think on Twitter musk is pretty
clued into where the the tech is going
and the tech is going towards
decentralization it's going towards
um platforms that are open that are
protocol based which means that nobody
owns it it's just like email like no one
owns email you you can use it as you
wish and we're seeing the emergency of
these kinds of platforms or at least
these Technologies like Noster is one of
them and farcaster minds.com and it it
what it means is that you can just talk
freely you don't have to ask permission
you have to raise your hand to ask
teacher if you can say this or that and
it also means that when someone says
something hateful or when they express
something that is violent you don't just
kick them off into an even darker corner
of the internet but you're able to
intervene and to help them if you'd like
more sane takes on our insane World
check out our direct message clips
playlist and if you want to watch more
full episodes of our live roundtables
watch our round tables playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell